given that you were getting scripts
one at a time what was it like with both
you and hamish being
on the show did did you have a situation
where you guys couldn't
talk about it because your character had
no idea what his was going through
that's a great question i think before
we were shooting i had read quite a few
more
but definitely there were scripts that
we were getting while we were shooting
but we were in such lockstep with
harriet
that uh you know i was never turning the
page and like what
it was um but
i think the truth is
we knew so i can say now spoil this is
spoilery
um we knew we would end up
getting to be together we just didn't
know exactly when and
uh and we lo i
i cons i love acting with him so much
and uh
so i just couldn't wait to get to the
script where i was going to
turn the page and see that we were
finally together um
no matter how uh how brutal the
circumstances
um might be because you know that's the
show
we were making and when it makes me
have that feeling of terror about
you know doing something that usually
makes me
feel also very excited to do it um i
don't
i don't sort of feel that i'm drawn
towards being particularly
comfortable not to say i don't love uh
i don't love doing shows where good
things are happening to people
but uh because i love that too but but
you know i i
uh if you're gonna if you're gonna get
out of bed
and leave your kids and i i want it to
i want it to feel um
challenging and and like unlike anything
i've done before and
so yeah i i i know it's i'm not really
answering your question but
we we would talk you know and we also
would i think we were without
saying let's have a lot of boundaries
about this there were things that we
didn't talk about
i think we just had we're we're um we've
worked together so many times
that there is a
there is a kind of dialogue that we have
that is very different than you know in
the way we are as a couple or as
co-parents
uh and and and we can be quite
boundaried when we know that it will
serve the work and uh and not over share
or not and withhold quite a bit and so
you know there wasn't we weren't like
coming to set to see what the other
person was doing leading up or who
who so that we did kind of meet these
characters
as they would have met uh it wasn't like
i was
um we weren't running lines with one
another in the way that we might have if
if one of us was working and the other
one wasn't
so there was a bit of um
we were kind of keeping keeping
character secrets from one another
i love that you guys could share that
passion together though that's so cool
to me
um i got two more spoiler questions for
you uh i don't know if this is something
you had the heads up on
earlier or you discovered it in the
script as you read along
but what was your reaction to the big
reveal
of what teresa really did
did it kind of uh was there a before and
after in terms of how you viewed karen
after getting that information
listen the thing about karen to me that
i love is that
she is wide open and she is someone who
sees the good in people
and i think we so often
when people are trusting of others we
like to say that they're overly trusting
or that they're in some ways
that there's a lack of intelligence in
being
trusting that being trusting means
you're gullible i
just wholeheartedly disagree i think
it's such a beautiful thing
to innately believe that people are good
and to to sort of lead with love and
um that's that's who she is
that's how she ends up in
in a lot of these relationships and in
the situation she does
so i never judged her for a second i
never
thought oh how could you not have how
what you know i
it was such a painful pleasure to get to
play someone who is so guileless in that
way and so
um optimistic about people
which is so completely on the opposite
side of the spectrum from
from where um emma ends up in terms of
being afraid of everyone really and
trusting no one including herself